[Music]
this is BS this is BS why are we here
this was put on the TV since schedule by
day sir
when I was told I had to send it no clue
why you're here and you not being here
would have made my job a lot easier
could I just played Animal Crossing all
day I'm so mad this is Michael Scott he
could have at least pretended to push
some buttons on the phone who's buying
this
there's no way anyone is buying this
right and if there's no chance that
anyone would buy this then there's no
chance that any of this is funny why is
this scene everybody I just got off the
Horn with corporate and basically I told
them where they could stick their little
overtime assignment go enjoy your Friday
but the clock showed it was only 425
were they supposed to be off by 4:00 or
something because Dolly Parton always
told me it was 9:00 to 5:00 honestly
also doesn't make sense because that
would imply you have no lunch break so
it really should be a very 30 to 5 and I
have to send the show for making Mead
I'm into that mentally stressful
wormhole why are these two people have
levitating heads Melo how many candles
do you need in one room attempting a
seance is their home a shrine did they
know about electricity she's starting a
candle making business no no nobody
Gamble's is Dolson should we do the tour
firs first tour wrong food always wins
Plus shouldn't tour wait until Andy and
Angela have arrived as well carpet Jamin
Oh feed them at the floor I cannot
create in the same space that I visit
either which is why I just choose to eat
peanut butter crackers and watch TJ
Hooker reruns in my office I do all the
sitting from the bathtub
this is a hundred percent in character
but terrible Sean Connery slash James
Bond impressions are always a sip guess
what white necks feel white are exactly
the same color Michael Scott would be
great at TV since I finally broke down
and bought myself a plasma TV oh come on
when did Michael Scott take the Homer
Simpson journey to a negative IQ I mean
there's being socially unaware and then
there's being dumb as a pallet of paper
it's hard to buy into a character that
becomes the ladder oh I also built this
table and now we have Michael bragging
about building a piece of table that no
one would ever brag about if anything
Michael would do a terrible Tim Allen
impression here and joke about how he's
seriously incompetent when it comes to
home improvement you know Pam it's
they often don't even start you can tell
me tonight I mean usually more like
10:00 p.m. but that's because most
Spaniards work until 8:00 and the Sun
doesn't often set until 10:00 this is
because Spain changed to the wrong time
zone in 1940 as a sign of solidarity
with Nazi Germany so basically the sin
is Nazis their times up for both also
one serious disservice this show did was
to the character of Janne she was a
strong brash female in power who didn't
put up with Michael and then they turned
her into his jobless girlfriend who all
the sudden acted as strangely and
inappropriately as he does who on you
the office who on you
you know what Hunter was a terrible
assistant cool that stereo has an
automatic conversational volume adjuster
not the thing right just so we're on the
same page the camera person followed Pam
into the bathroom for this interview
right Michael and Jan seemed to be
playing their own separate game and it's
called let's see how uncomfortable we
can make our guests and the show is
playing a game called let's see how
uncomfortable we can make our audience
is that much better apparently my
apartment flooded ma'am we should
probably get going and see the damage oh
that's true
Oh golf show this is absolutely where
Jim would disagree and emphasize that
two heads are better than one and they
would both just leave offering their
apologies but even one camera sitcoms
got a sitcom I guess no literally no one
reads the paper know what it would look
like if Paul Feig directed marriage
story know what girls trip Angela come
on girls trip I'd give every sin back if
this ends up with champion while
suspended on a zipline
or Pam making friends with a grapefruit
came here to eat dinner unto party this
is a dinner party right role commercials
you said that I could not invite Dwight
because he was not part of a couple and
because we didn't have enough wine
glasses why is Michael acting like he
wants Dwight here now the show is
infuriatingly and falsely creating these
scenes of tension too fast for me to
keep up at the beginning Michael did
mention the wine glass issue to Dwight
but he also seemed to be inviting Angela
and Andy at the last minute and I guess
Jan being the reason he didn't invite
Dwight could be considered a twist but
it's not a good one and Michael has
tried to get out of doing things with
Dwight constantly throughout this series
even tries to get out of going to his
house at the end of this episode
the thought of popping one of your beats
into my mouth makes me want to vomit you
know what they say about Dwight's beats
one pop and you just can't stop and I
think we're talking about balls now if
Michael honestly believe that mine would
he have these two couples over for a
dinner party I get he doesn't have much
common sense but he's got enough to not
have the possibility of four possible
murders on his conscience haha because
old people don't understand technology
you're too good for this type of on
creative lowbrow humor in the office you
usually reward us with much more
creative lowbrow humor you're telling me
that large painting was hanging up there
balanced with one nail because I did not
believe you this is supposed to be funny
seriously I'm genuinely asking because
they can't be trying to pull an actual
human emotion out of this cringefest
right I'm going Amish for hold of the
ass cuz the more I watch this show the
more I realized white is a straight-up
dick and straight-up dicks often does
their sinning I stole this and of course
the episode returns to turn us around
with a little bit of the awesomeness
that is Jim and Pam honest I like them I
do but this entire episode seems to be
all about how depressingly awful and
most couples are but then the Jim and
Pam cherry isn't gonna save the
relationship turd Sunday in the
slightest
when I was his age I had four or five
girlfriends at one time he was he was
his cousin
I wasn't seeing my cousin make sure you
click that Bell icon but clicking the
little bell icon is how you make sure
you get notified every time we release a
video so click it so it will be me and
JN and ham and Jim and Angela and Andy
Kumar we got you this I am not kidding
me Marlo this is my workspace this is it
check that out you smell it it's quite
pungent I love it lovely you inhale it
you man and I am the devil